[ __ ] up swanson it's like you said death
is natural and sal lived a good long
life but so much is changing
and i've never been a fan of change
salvatore
was a constant in my life in my
experience the only constant is change
ah
nice to see you ron
i couldn't help but over here
sure i'm sorry about your loss you know
every time we lose a compadre or a
collective lantern gets a little bit
dimmer hey you look awful familiar have
we met before i'm sure our souls have
collided in one lifetime or another no
that's not it are you in my frisbee golf
league oh yeah i play for the super
spinners oh i'm on the frisbee champs oh
cool i named us andrew stop speaking to
this man he is the worst human being on
earth oh come on
death makes brothers of us all
i've always found it when my soul aches
with loss
it's best to turn to eastern wisdom this
is from the isle of isla in scotland
this is as eastern as my wisdom gets
swanson this handsome spiritual cowboy
may actually be right about turning to
the east
i have an idea
trust me
who cuts your hair nobody whenever my
hair feels it has completed his journey
it simply sheds itself off i hate you
so much
and i love you my brother
donna this is crazy typhoon is an artist
and the human head is his canvas just
listen you're gonna cut the man's hair
you're gonna charge him eight dollars
it'll take you four minutes so just shut
up and make the man look like this
fine
so typhoon
what do you like to do for fun i'm
writing an electronic opera about
brittany murphy and i do the chandelier
design for my friend's drag puppet show
no further questions all i really want
to do is dance except lately all the
good warehouse waves are filled with
euro trash
euro trash i like that
it is indeed a garbage continent yes oh
my god i had the worst time in berlin
last may everyone was on their stupid
bikes that was like ew
talk more about how you hate europe and
bicycles
hello miss knope
hello former strange person i used to
friend
you're looking very
ron-like
you have your same hair no i don't i
have bangs now i've never known what
bangs are and i don't intend to learn oh
maybe you should
yeah you're not going to win 50 million
you freak maybe not but i'm not not
going to win nothing
paul
that guy is a joke this lawsuit is
definitely getting thrown out i don't
know those are john ralphia's lawyers
they once got him 60 000 because he got
too scared at a haunted house
and what exactly did you witness
defendant alias ron swanson alias
my boss
used appropriate force to prevent
further damage to the wedding of leslie
knope alias my other boss you sound as
if you have a special interest in law
enforcement yes sir in fact at the time
i was trying to become a police officer
but was deemed unfit for the force and
what happened don't know well i pooched
the brain exam just to be safe i
wouldn't take anything i say too
seriously
next witness your honor ms ludgate have
you ever heard mr swanson threaten to
hurt councilman jim ronnie are you
kidding me
i've never heard him threaten to hurt
anyone or anything the guy's like a
vegetarian
look at him he's like a big old soft
teddy bear his nickname around the
office is
softy pants mchuggable did you ever hear
mr swanson say he intended to injure
councilman jim before the day of the
wedding the answer is a flat no
ron doesn't really pay much attention to
other people i doubt he even knew you
existed also man stay for the record
that is a dope pocket square can i see
that bad boy
tom and april were excellent witnesses
in my defense
unfortunately every single word out of
their miles was a lie there's only one
thing i hate more than lying
skim milk which is water that's lying
about being milk
is that a travel pillow around your neck
ron
i don't know how to explain this to you
when you've been down in the pit have
you been in the pit
no i haven't gotten down there yet well
i have when you fell in when i visited
the bottom of the pit on a fact-finding
mission
and when you're down there you get some
perspective about
what it all means
let me tell you something ron
what it means is
i want this subcommittee
i've been quite open about this around
the office i don't want this parks
department to build any parks because i
don't believe in government i think that
all government is a waste of taxpayer
money
my dream
is to have the park system privatized
and run entirely for profit by
corporations
like chuck e cheese
they have an impeccable business model i
would rather work for chuck e cheese
ron swanson it is my pleasure to inform
you that you are a finalist for the job
of assistant city manager chris i feel i
should remind you that i do not believe
that the position or the entire
government should exist that said you'd
be a fool not to pick me i will walk
deeper into the belly of the beast if it
means i'm able to further limit reckless
government spending i mean i have so
many ideas
some are simple like take down traffic
lights and eliminate the post office the
bigger ones will be tougher like
bring all of this crumbling to the
ground
so after all that it's really not that
bad
you're gonna get a letter in your file
ron i just wanted to say thank you don't
worry about it
no i didn't i didn't do it for leslie i
did it because i hate bureaucracy my
idea of a perfect government is
one guy who sits in a small room at a
desk and the only thing he's allowed to
decide is who to nuke
the man is chosen based on some kind of
iq test
and maybe also a physical tournament
like a decathlon
and women
are brought to him maybe
when he desires them
hey bro listen i was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b25
mitchell panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and i went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey ron
swanson
check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are
yeah
okay um
there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site and buy
something it'll remember you and then
create ads for other stuff you might
want to buy so it learns information
about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to google
earth and type in your address
well diane for potholes you want to
speak with public works
i understand you've tried them four
times government is inefficient and
should be dissolved please hold while i
transfer you would you like to sample
our vegan bacon
100 meatless
yes please
another please
sir is there a problem i'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this
i i don't think i can give you any more
i want one
what a gorgeous herbaceous medley
there's been a mistake you've
accidentally given me the food that my
food eats salad is traditionally the
first course at a wedding is a gerbil
marrying a rabbit
i couldn't care less about the
commendation
but indianapolis is home to charles
mulligan's steakhouse the best damn
steakhouse in the damn state i have
taken a picture
of every steak i've ever eaten there
june 2004 porterhouse medium rare
bearnaise sauce january 2000 they call
this one the enforcer february 96 the
stake rib eye the whiskey lagavulin 16.
the lady next to me a [ __ ]
specifically my ex-wife tammy okay this
is this is the first time i ever went
there
look at me
just a kid
ron would you like some salad
since i am not a rabbit no i do not try
it sounds good for you you got it
mmm
delicious
ron
what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the steak
oh there's no steak that's a healthier
option it's organically grown
can you get us a cold compress or
something
you